au delà de la france de nombreux pays
européens s'inquiètent une reprise
épidémique notamment la russie en cause
notamment la forte circulation du
variant delta du corona virus face à
cette nouvelle vague moscou lance une
campagne de reval six nations en
proposant une troisième injection la
correspondance de vera goffman plus de 3
millions de moscovites ont déjà reçu au
moins une dose du vaccin a déclaré le
maire de la capitale sergueï sobianine
il vient d'inaugurer un nouveau centre
de vaccination capable d'accueillir plus
de 6000 personnes par jour pour sergueï
sobianine
il est crucial de se protéger contre la
pandémie qui s'accélère je vous propose
d'écouter
aujourd'hui nous avons atteint la barre
des trois millions de personnes qui ont
reçu la première dose du vaccin
important pour se protéger contre la
pandémie qui s'accélère je suis très
reconnaissant envers les habitants de
moscou qui se sont montrés responsables
par rapport à leur santé et celle de
leurs proches
aujourd'hui nous ouvrons l'un des plus
grands centres de vaccination d'europe
et le plus grand de russie
la capacité standard de ce centre est de
6000 personnes par jour dans le cas d'un
afflux plus important il sera tout à
fait possible de prolonger les heures
d'ouverture et sa capacité augmentera en
conséquence toute une équipe de médecins
d'infirmières d'employés de centre
multifonctionnel de service public et de
bénévoles a été constitué afin d'assurer
une vaccination rapide et confortable à
ceux qui souhaitent venir ici malgré la
hausse du nombre des contaminations les
autorités n'envisage toujours pas de
confinement mais appelle la population à
se faire vacciner le plus vite possible
afin d'éviter le retour aux restrictions
les plus drastiques le de 24000 de
nouveaux cas de corona virus ont été
détectés a aussi à dernières 24 heures
dont plus de 6500 à mousse